We're asked to
categorize the value
of each exponential expression.
And we categorize
each expression
into either the bucket
less than negative 1,
between negative 1 and
0, and between 0 and 1.
And I encourage you
to pause this video
and try this out on your own.
So I assume you've
given a go at it.
Now let's work
through it together.
So I just copy and pasted
the exact same exercise right
over here.
And let's think about
each of these expressions.
And actually, before
doing that, I actually
want to draw a number line to
think about these categories.
So it looks like
the important things
to consider-- you have a 0.
You have 1.
And then you have negative 1.
This first category right over
here, less than negative 1,
that's all of these
values right over there.
Then you have the category
between negative 1 and 0.
That's these values
right over there.
And then finally, you have
the category between 0 and 1.
That's this category
right over here.
So they didn't give us a
bucket for greater than 1,
so I guess it's safe to
assume that none of these
are going to be greater than 1.
But let's go each expression
by each expression.
So this first expression, 7
to the negative fourth power,
we've already talked
about several times,
that when you raise something
to a negative exponent,
this isn't somehow negative 7
to the fourth power or anything
like that.
When you see a negative
number in an exponent,
you should immediately
think reciprocal.
So this is going to
be equal to 1 over 7
to the positive fourth power.
And you don't even have to
know what 7 to the fourth
actually is.
It's 2,401, if
you're interested.
But you don't even
have to know that.
You just know that
this right over here
is going to be a large
positive number, so 1 over that
is going to be a very
small positive number.
It's going to be
between 0 and 1.
This is actually one 1/2,401,
but you don't even have to know
that.
This is a large
number, and so you say,
well, this is going
to get pretty close.
It's positive, so it's
going to be above 0.
But it's not going to
be too much above 0.
It's going to sit on the
number line-- actually,
I'm not even doing
justice right over there.
The way I drew it, at
scale, it's not even
a pixel to the right
of 0 right over there.
So this is going to
be between 0 and 1.
And actually, I'll
draw lines like this,
to show roughly on our number
line, where it would sit.
Now let's think about
negative 7 to the third power.
So negative 7 to the
third power, well,
this is the same thing
as negative 7 times
negative 7 times negative 7.
And you could also think
about this as negative 1 times
7 times negative 1 times
7, which is the
same thing as-- you
have three negative 1's
being multiplied together--
so negative 1 to the third power
times 7 to the third power.
Well, what's negative
1 to the third power?
Well, it's negative
1 times negative 1,
which would be positive 1, but
then times another negative 1.
So this is negative
1 right over here.
So this is going to be equal
to-- let me write it this way.
You could write it either
as-- I could write it
like this-- negative
7 to the third power.
So 7 to the third,
once again, we
don't even have to
know what it is.
This is going to be a
large positive value.
But then we're negating it.
If we had 7 to the third,
it would be greater than 1.
But negative 7 to the
third is definitely
less than negative 1.
So this fits into that
bucket right over there.
Now we have negative 7
to the negative fourth.
So let me write it over
here-- so negative 7
to the negative fourth.
So this could be
a little daunting
because you have a negative base
raised to a negative exponent.
But whenever I see
a negative exponent,
the first thing I worry about or
the first thing my brain wants
to do is take a reciprocal.
So this is going to be 1 over
negative 7 to the fourth power.
And once again, the same
idea as we just saw over
here, we could view this
as 1 over negative 1
to the fourth power times 7
to the fourth power, which
is going to be equal to--
negative 1 to the fourth power,
this is just going
to be equal to 1.
So this is going to be equal to
1 over 7 to the fourth power.
Well, we've already
thought about what 1 over 7
to the fourth power is.
It is between 0 and 1.
So this right over here
is between 0 and 1.
Another way you
can think about it,
this is going to be 1
over negative 7 times
negative 7 times negative
7 times negative 7.
You have a negative times a
negative times a negative times
a negative.
Well, that's going
to be a positive.
So it's positive 7
to the fourth power.
Now let's think about this one
right over here-- negative 7
to the negative fifth power.
So let me write this
out-- negative 7
to the negative fifth power.
Well once again, as soon as
you see that negative exponent,
I want to just take
the reciprocal,
so I don't have a
negative exponent anymore.
So it's 1 over negative
7 to the fifth power.
And we could rewrite
this as 1 over negative 1
to the fifth times 7
to the fifth, which
is equal to-- well, what's a
negative 1 to the fifth power?
Well a negative 1
raised to an odd power
is going to be a negative 1.
So this is going to be negative
1 over 7 to the fifth power.
So where is 1 over 7
to the fifth power?
Well, that would be
really close to 0.
This would be positive.
1 over 7 to the fifth would be
a very small positive number.
But now we're taking
the negative of that.
So we're going to jump on
to the other side of 0.
So this is going to be
between negative 1 and 0.
And then finally, negative
7 to the fifth power,
well that's just going
to be-- this, once again,
you could view that
as negative 1 times
7 to the fifth power, which is
the same thing as negative 1
to the fifth times 7
to the fifth, which
is the same thing as
negative 7 to the fifth.
7 to the fifth is a very
large number, larger than 1.
So the negative of that is going
to be a very negative number.
It's going to be
less than negative 1.
So this is going to be less
than negative 1 right over here.
So now let's take our results.
And since I have
a bad memory, I'm
essentially probably going to
have to think through it again.
And let's actually put
them in the buckets.
7 to the negative
fourth power-- this
is not going to be
a negative value.
This is 1 over 7 to the fourth.
This is going to
be between 0 and 1.
Negative 7 to the third
power-- that's essentially,
if you take 7 to
the third power,
you get a very large
positive number.
But then, since that's
going to be times negative 1
to the third power,
it's going to be
the negative version of that.
So that's going to be
less than negative 1.
Negative 7 to the
negative fourth-- well,
we already determined,
especially because this ends up
being 1 over negative
7 to the fourth power
and that's an even exponent,
it ends up being the same as 7
to the negative fourth.
And then you had negative 7
to the negative fifth power.
So once again, that was
going to be 1 over negative 7
to the fifth power.
And so we found that to be
between negative 1 and 0.
And then finally,
this right over here,
it's going to be negative.
And it's going to be a
very negative number.
It's less than negative 1.
And so those are our choices.
And we can check our
answer, and we got it right.